parce que quand vous vous êtes réveillé
ce matin vous avez ouvert l'oeil
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit en premier
je l'ai ouvert sur le fermer
moi je me suis dit effectivement qu'on
avait peut-être sous-estimé le score de
d'Emmanuel Lepers Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron
tout des Français qui l'interpellent
n'est pas beaucoup les retraités
non mais on peut revenir sans cesse je
vous invite à avoir la vidéo vos
collègues du Parisien doivent avoir
eux-mêmes peuvent en témoigner sorti de
son contexte on peut faire dire tout et
n'importe quoi voilà
qui ne dit pas toute la vérité et du
corps très bien moi j'ai jamais insulté
personne j'ai fait applaudir vous savez
hier j'ai fait le dire par l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui ont voté pour moi au
premier tour tous les autres candidats
Go là c'est pas mais vous pouvez pas te
dire tout et son contraire non je trouve
étonnant vous avez pourquoi pas mais je
trouve étonnant que vous le fassiez je
suis une première les trois candidats en
tête sont connus le président sortant
bien évidemment et et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on est à ça 3e candidature Marine Le Pen
à sa troisième ça doit être derrière la
huitième de la de la famille Le Pen
c'est les gens qui sont dans le paysage
installés connus que les Français parce
que il y a la fois
2027 mais je me prépare 27 ou 32 mais
mais non
énormément de gens ont voté hier
notamment et ben on attendait plus mais
Xavier
il l'a dit
je crois que c'est un compte parodique
je suis fatigué que ce soit lui qui l'a
dit mais en tout cas si c'est lui
vraiment c'est les gens cherchent pas
bien il est dans quel pays vous êtes à
combien ce soir notre société de micro
on vous entend pas
il est visible grande démocratie
quelle est la vie elle parcours
politique de Emmanuel Nicolas Sarkozy
non
il n'a jamais quitter sa famille
politique jamais et dans des moments
très compliqués très difficiles
non mais c'est bon là on peut pas y
aller la Réunion en tout cas promet
d'être très chaude ici au siège des
républicains et la situation peut se
résumer finalement à une image qu'on a
capté ce matin ici attention sol
glissant c'est le panneau qui était
installé à l'entrée du siège du parti
tout à l'heure il n'est pas interdit d'y
voir une métaphore politique campagne la
plus chère celle de la candidate les
républicains a coûté 14,5 millions
d'euros
mais ce matin c'est la gueule de bois à
quelques milliers de voix près elle ne
passe pas la barre fatidique et doit
trouver 7 millions d'euros pour rentrer
dans ses frais nous n'avons pas atteint
les 5%
qui nous permettraient d'obtenir les 7
millions de remboursement de l'État que
nous étions c'est 7 millions de
remboursement manque pour boucler le
budget de la campagne
les républicains ne peuvent pas faire
face à ces dépenses et décidément la vie
est pleine de surprises en une semaine
on peut complètement changer de
stratégie la dignité c'est par le
travail et pas par l'assistanat je veux
rendre l'argent aux Français je suis
endetté personnellement à hauteur de 5
millions d'euros
c'est pour cela que je lance ce matin un
appel national au don à tous ceux qui
m'ont apporté leur suffrage mais aussi à
tous ceux qui ont préféré hier le vote
utile
mobiliser
vraiment mobilisez-vous pour Valérie
Pécresse non mais sérieux c'est un truc
de fou là c'est non mais c'est là avec
moi